donnez vous savez qu'aujourd'hui on a un
petit peu le coeur gros nous à radio
canada et rdi et si vous en êtes
d'accord
alors pour les gens qui ne savaient pas
parce que beaucoup de gens recommencent
à savoir maintenant denis vit sa
dernière journée avec nous comme membre
de notre équipe
évidemment la vie va continuer alors
donc celle annonce de votre retraite on
est en train de faire le déni ni plus ni
moins j'essaie manette impression j'ai
dit c'est que moi vous vivez sur la
dernière journée bien coûter c'est une
vraie journée typique avec de la vraie
nouvelle avec ce qu'ils ont mais en même
temps essayer de combiner ça à un départ
de vous ça c'est spécial parce qu'il ya
un gros bac de recyclage dans mon bureau
en même temps que je donc je dois
équilibrer la journée mais là qu'ils se
tournent l'excès excellent excellent
l'emportent nettement il va y avoir du
retard
alors vous avez eu un gros saut tonnes
aussi on souligne de campagne électorale
vous allez montpellier justement c'était
tellement un grand bonheur de travailler
avec vous et vous savez que j'ai des
collègues avec moi qui veulent aussi
vous dire au revoir et merci alors
sébastien bovet québec est avec nous
gerell fillion aussi est sur le plateau
alors on va y aller des commentaires
parce que tout le monde a envie de vous
parler du nouvel obs m
beaurevoir
là pour vous
eric besson j'ai côtoyé beaucoup fait
des années merci
c'est un succès 6 3
guy ilary beauté
alors donnez donnez le manifestement
beaucoup d'émotions ici dans la salle de
nouvelles
écoutez ils sont tellement nombreux que
les collègues se sont levés pour vous
saluer vous en voyez là mais il ya des
yeux qui brillent josé oui le brevet ici
aussi sourd alors j'aimerais donner la
parole à quelques personnes qui avaient
invite vous dire quelques mots on va
commencer avec gerald qui est à mes
côtés j'ai récemment il ya des
applaudissements aussi ottawa tandis
qu'en serrant vont prendre le temps on
s'est dit bonjour aux cas l'aide
d'ottawa qui mettrait aussi apprécié à
tahoua je comprends bien partout partout
bon alors je rêve qu'est ce que me suis
fait que monter le chauffage ainsi denis
est ce que vous entendez encore avec
madame st louis blues joué que moi je
sais de l'industrie portrait non pas que
je vous connais ya des gens qui me
connaissent depuis très très longtemps
parce que vous avez fait carrière au
tour des cloîtres ans demeure à lyon oui
c'est vraiment moi je veux vendre qui
est ce qu'on va faire au dj de renard a
dans les huis clos budgétaire pour
qu'enfin le budget parce qu'il faut
savoir qu'avec de nice terrain quand on
est tous budgets on cherche toute la
journée les bonnes informations
et c'est toujours de nick et lisa à la
bonne page à leur sens
j'en verrais bien mes coordonnées
personnelles mais n'étant pas dans la
vidéo vous n'aurez pas accès aux données
quand on est dans le budget et je veux
juste montrer de quoi ça a l'air de
budget tout simplement pour vous que
vous voyez le deux modes pour lire
parfois en cinq ou six heures et
généralement on cherche comme ça c'est
quoi le chiffre exactement il ya
toujours denis ferland qui est à côté du
pacha 70 le chiffre est là c'est 65
millions alors ça c'est denis ferland il
à la précision il a la connaissance
il comprend comment ça fonctionne il a
une profonde connaissance de ces
informations là et il s'est livré il
sait les communiqués capter cette
information et la livrer ensuite
alors sache je pense comme journaliste à
radio canada la justesse de
l'information et la crédibilité mais
aussi la l'equilibre dans la
présentation de l'information
nous cherchons ça il y avait daniel
l'heureux avant qui faisaient ça avant
denis ferland denis ferland le fait dans
les dernières années
sébastien beauvais le fait avec brio
aussi à québec mais notre ami fernand je
pense qu'il le fait avec avec beaucoup
beaucoup de doigté de et de force
on voit des archives de goût de 1995 la
barre depuis lombard oui la barbe les
plus longues effectivement alors vous
êtes effectivement une référence comme
le dit gérald un modèle aussi quelques
mauvais que cbc novik se joint à nous
qui est à québec ce bastion de laisse la
parole moi je vous dirais que denis
ferland c'est un canard parce que je
suis un cador aussi salaire très calme
en surface tout le monde veut comprendre
qu'il maîtrise très bien ses dossiers
mais en dessous de l'eau on [ __ ] et
les gens qui pensent qu'il ya des gens
qui vont nous chercher notre café qui
font cuire notre lunch le midi qui nous
attendrait toutes sortes de
documentation quand on arrive au bureau
pour comprendre et vulgariser
l'information mais c'est pas le cas du
tout on n'est pas laissés à nous mêmes
parce qu'on a des équipes formidables
travaillent avec nous mais il ya un
travail de fond exceptionnel qu'il faut
faire pour atteindre la qualité le
niveau de qualité de vulgarisation que
denis ferland a atteint au fil des ans
et moi c'est l'hommage que je voudrais
lui
andrade ni parce que comme gérald eux
disaient pour vulgariser les choses pour
nous le faire comprendre prendre des
événements complexes et les faire
comprendre à la population il n'y avait
pas quelqu'un de pareils comme lui et
c'est l'hommage que je te rendre
aujourd'hui denis parce que je sais
exactement ce que c'est de marcher dans
tes souliers d'une capitale à l'autre
merci c'est assez courte mais aussi six
ans comme toi c'est ce particulièrement
révélateur aulas avoue dit aussi tout
autant de coeur à québec vous allez
manquer à tout le monde
denis vous savez il ya des gens qui vous
ont préféré une ce quelque chose on
voulait pas vous laisser partir sans sa
non règlement on veut l'écouter et cathy
denis ferland prend sa retraite
aujourd'hui si jeune et glissez pas
denis l'homme et il m'a déjà sauvé la
vie watts ke ya contribué à me rendre
plus intelligent avoir la plus
intelligente non parce que j'ai passat
est déjà arrivé mais moi en tant que
jeune reporter en atlantique
ben des fois on avait la visite de
ministres fédéraux ou encore du premier
ministre la jeune journaliste je devais
aller couvrir jusqu'à mal à la venue de
par exemple stephen harper et là nous on
avait beau lire tous les articles de
journaux mais la meilleure façon d'être
bien préparés de poser une question
intelligente
c'était d'appeler denis ferland ottawa
puis même si nous on avait trois quatre
heures devant nous pluie avait juste
cinq minutes il prenait quand même le 5
minutes
denis merci donc pour m'avoir aidé à
poser peut-être une ou deux questions
intelligentes soin aux ministres la
défense au premier ministre et puis
vraiment c'était un honneur de
travailler avec toi surtout de
t'entendre en ondes à chaque jour et
puis aussi apprécié ton esprit de
synthèse qui est vraiment remarquable
qui nous aspire à tous les jours et moi
j'ai connu denis quand j'étais stagiaire
j'étais en train de terminer ma maîtrise
à témoin la à l'hiver 2001 daniel
lessard me présenter mon superviseur de
stage qui était donné favori way des
premières choses que denis m'a dit c'est
moi aussi j'ai eu les cheveux longs
comme toi quand j'étais plus jeune donc
il voulait toujours être cool
à la fin de mon stage me dit parler à
une certaine emmanuelle latraverse qui
est ainsi pas qu'à l'époque
emmanuel qui me donnait de très bons
conseils dans de faire un démo
oblige à faire un démo est le démon je
les montre et admis à la toute fin
kirby d'une fin de semaine de deux
courts de tennis ou de en fait de deux
parties de tennis donc avait mal au dos
mais à monter du 5e ou 6e avec ténue
misère et au le vu ce que la f1 il a eu
tout ce que j'avais compris ils étaient
contents ça c'est mon dos et c'était une
belle partance alors merci denis pour
tout ça merci de ta présence merci de
tes encouragements merci d'avoir été
calme dans toutes ces années parce que
oui on était jeunes on posait plus une
question était excité il semble qu'il
était toujours apaise il nous a toujours
aidés merci denis et surtout bonne
recette
merci pascal mary keitany tous les
jeunes journalistes sont chanceux de
t'avoir vu comme modèle moi tu m'a
montré que pour atteindre un tel niveau
de professionnalisme et de maîtrise de
ces dossiers ya pas de secret ça prend
ce travail du dévouement et du temps ce
que je retiens surtout c'est ton
accessibilité la disponibilité et était
toujours disponible
on avait besoin de tes conseils merci
beaucoup denis pour ta generis
générosité c'est ce qui nous marquent
quand on pense à denis parce que au
cours de la campagne électorale
dernièrement ne serait-ce que c'est ce
bout-là de ta carrière bat a été d'une
générosité avec nous tu nous expliquer
tout ce qu'on devait savoir tu as des
chiffres en teck personnes ne peuvent
avoir et ça c'est très important
on peut sortir un gars de la politique
mais je pense pas qu'on puisse sortir la
politique du gaz bonne retraite je pense
qu'on va se revoir au revoir mais mon
cher dany perd rien de tes bonnes
habitudes et continue de nous écouter
comme ça à tous les matins oui de nous
suivre nous surveiller de tout ce
travail que vous avez fait et vous êtes
bienvenu dans le studio un bandit du
sonnet prendre à tout moment attention
alors denis je te souhaite encore une
fois une très très bonne de retraite
j'espère que tu seras en profite et je
dois dire que là dessus je n'ai
absolument aucun doute je sais que tu as
l'imagination très fertile et je pense
que c'est la troisième fois que je te le
souhaite
comme ça tout finir par penser que je
souhaitais au départ bien loin de là
j'ai toujours apprécié travailler avec
toi et je suis convaincu qu'on aura
l'occasion d'en discuter
éventuellement autour d'une bière
probablement j'espère que
souvent profiter des prochains mois
pourtant refaire une santé d'abord et
ensuite croire peut-être ce que tu
pourrais faire venir peut-être dans le
secteur des communications ou ailleurs
et ça a été un plaisir de travailler
avec toi je garde d'excellents souvenirs
notamment ce voyage qu'on avait fait
ensemble en union soviétique il ya déjà
belle lurette
vous avez été des moments qui vont
rester à jamais gravé dans ma mémoire
denis merci encore une fois au plaisir
est alors de nice a fait beaucoup un
bruit dommage john cena vous énormément
besoin de tels parents du contenu avec
l'en l'éventail d'intervenants il y
avait ça couvre à peu près toutes les
années parce que mitchell était là dès
le départ 78 79
il ya des plus jeunes je suis très
content d'avoir vu des plus jeunes
d'avoir attendu des plus jeunes aussi
parce que ça me tient beaucoup à coeur
des stagiaires j'en ai pris dans l'à peu
près tous les emplois au fil des années
puis j'essaie c'est quelque chose qui me
touche particulièrement des warriors et
tous les gens qui ont travaillé avec
vous rendent hommage justement votre
immense générosité dont j'ai bénéficié
aussi pendant cette campagne électorale
vous savez on est très moderne
maintenant on est rendus dans les
réseaux sociaux et même sur les réseaux
sociaux les gens ont quelque chose à
vous il ya philippe antoine sonic est à
mes côtés pour vous rapporter justement
ces témoignages alors ce grand fini
maintenant
mais denis ya beaucoup de gens qui ont
écouté et apprécié et pris la peine de
commenter une entrevue qu on trouve
notamment sur facebook et sur le site de
radio canada une entrevue que vous avez
accordée à notre collègue et que vous
connaissez bien alain gravel animateur à
l'émission du matin à montréal gravel le
matin une entrevue dans laquelle vous
êtes revenu sur sur les faits marquants
de votre carrière au cours des dernières
décennies et beaucoup de gens ont pris
la peine de mettre des commentaires à la
suite de cette publication pour dire
combien il appréciait votre travail
combien il aimait vous voir tous les
jours à rdi pour dire jusqu'à quel point
vous allez leur manquait beaucoup
beaucoup de commentaires dont certains
de gens que vous avez connu à gauche et
à droite et on
retenus quelques heures ici par exemple
bernard bigras ancien député à la
chambre des communes
petit qui écrivent de bons souvenirs de
monsieur ferland à l'occasion d'un
passage comme député à avoir prenez soin
de vous la politique et sa couverture
médiatique sont exigeantes et épuisante
un autre commentaire celui de reale
damour ancien journaliste à radio canada
à moins chic type
connaissant et sans prétention bonne
retraite l'écrit real d'amour et enfin
jacques tétrault que vous avez connu
assez cassé avec d'autres anciens
collègues
j'ai connu
j'ai connu a tenu à sécurité critique où
il était un des meilleurs rédacteurs de
nouvelles de sa génération avec le
meilleur lecteur qui soit michel vieille
qu'on connaît tous avec à ses côtés des
reporters comme un certain alain gravel
denis avait un sens aiguisé de la
nouvelle avec le juste mot pour
l'exprimer à chaque fois à la retraite
dit jacques tétrault je ne le crois pas
avec un petit sourire en coin parce que
plusieurs souhaitent évidemment pour
avoir quelque part peut-être comme
analyste et les commentaires sont
élogieux ont dit vous un grand
journaliste d'un grand homme qui quitte
le diffuseur public un analyste brillant
professionnelle et impartiale et ya même
quelqu'un qui dit au nom des jeunes
qu'aux non il commençait à peine sa
carrière celui là en amérique l ue bout
évidemment je me suis je me joins à tous
ces gens là denis pour vous souhaiter
une bonne retraite pour enfin vous avez
la réponse à ccc aux fins non mais
écoutez j'ai je pense que on peut je
vais dévoiler un secret parce que pascal
disait dans quelle mesure je l'avais
aidé à avoir l'air plus intelligent lors
de certaines entrevues
nous sommes des petits trucs ici c'est
exactement l'argument d'utiliser auprès
des par exemple petites anecdotes des
attachés de presse de ministre quand on
s'apprête à couvrir une annonce en
direct on a l'air très préparée sur
l'air de bien absorber l'ensemble de
l'annonce c'est parfois quand même un
petit 5 10 minutes à l'avant sont un
petit document sous embargo qui nous
permet justement c'est l'argument
utilisé d'avoir l'air moins niaiseux ou
plus intelligent pour l'annoncé alors
bon oui c'est vrai je travaille fort on
absorbe de la matière et tout ça mais on
a aussi de l'aide de l'autre côté de la
clôture parfois pour mais il faut
entretenir ses contacts ses bonnes
relations là ça fait partie du travail
de journaliste mais mais je dis moi au
sida à ce moment là j'en profite pour
remercier les gens bien sûr mais les
dernières on se dit semaine deux
semaines et demie à montréal jusqu'au 19
octobre m'ont quand même permis de
revoir une dernière fois j'étais à peu
près certain que c'était la dernière
fois dans ma tête parce que j'avais
mûrissait depuis un certain temps mais
j'ai savouré chacun à chacun des moments
chacune des journées les journées
passaient très vite les soirées c'était
plus étaient plus longs à montréal loin
des miens mais il reste que pour ce qui
est de la portion travail en salle de
nouvelles avec vos julie christine
beaucoup en journée anne marie le soir
très régulièrement
patrice à 17 heures et toute l'équipe
qui m'a soutenu ma chef de ces pirates
peuvent être la dernière alexandrine
tétreault 6 morts et 18 9 qui était
régulièrement plus petit électorale ça a
beaucoup facilité les choses mais je
remercie en particulier toutes les
équipes électorale à montréal qu'on
travaillait quand même depuis 1997 la
auprès de moi ça m'a ça m'a beaucoup
aidé et j'ai compté sur de bonnes
personnes mais partout où je suis passé
dans ma carrière en guillemets j'hésite
à utiliser le mot
écoutez c'est vraiment les au revoir
d'un gentleman d'un collègue qu'on a
beaucoup aimé monde le fait mais
j'aurais fillion qui est toujours à mes
côtés moi j'ai juste une question c est
pour celui qui ne quittent cette
fonctionnaire vu allez vous faire de la
politique monsieur faire la faire de la
politique je ne dirai jamais je fontaine
je ne boirai temps nommé e
non non faire de la politique
non c'est très hautes clôtures à son
hôte et je trouve à ok d'accord mais
merci encore et au revoir d'à part de
tout le monde et sébastien dernier petit
coucou aussi pour vous était un
gentleman puis je vais me souvenir
longtemps que toi merci beaucoup d'avoir
tracé le chemin particulier
merci bien sébastien est apprécié
c'était ma maman mon idole du direct
c'était sébastien est un peu un exemple
un exemple et une référence à leur jeu
d'autant plus touché c'est réciproque en
termes de référence merci d'un du salut
et merci à tous ceux qui sont joints à
nous pour vous dire au revoir et vous
dire un bonne soupe des choses bonnes
retraites on sait qu'elle se réactive
vous êtes un homme actif
alors voilà du fond du coeur de la part
de l'ensemble de l'équipe de toutes les
plateformes
radio-canada un gros gros merci pour
toutes ces années pour votre générosité
votre professionnel explique bonvin
soyez aux rues de nîmes
merci je salue les collègues de bureau à
ottawa et flamands qui je vais
m'intéresser de fleurs au roi